are you someone who's crazy about
Christmas I love Christmas I get
presents like growing up like for
Christmas I have one you know you do
it's a my first song I ever wrote on was
my cube we didn't have any money and my
my mom and everybody pulled together and
she totally on credit and and got me a
keyboard that's nice I think that my
family did give me a little like
sing-along microphone thing but then
they were like forget that that's not
gonna work out and then like every year
I wanted like baby dolls I really wanted
like because I really always just wanted
like a little baby doll and then one
year the like hot you know cool doll of
the year was this baby called baby feels
so real and you would touch the baby and
ever have like bones do you guys
remember this and I don't know why I
remember that doll cuz that's creepy
that's my daughter is like we should
make a doll and put bones in it yeah and
give it to children my daughter has a
crazy dog she doll that she loves and
you're like trying to misplace my dog
and it's super creepy and it looks like
it's from a haunted horror my main kind
of thing but I had a lot of those I had
a doll - where you had to teach it to
like learn words so I'd be like it's
Apple and there are like spaghetti and
it'd be like ask Eddie and I'd be like
no it's spaghetti like oh here argue
over and then and then they'd like get
it right and I was like I just taught
that dollar words gonna be a great man I
will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my youtube channel
that's right and I could talk a lot
seriously not gonna stop yep still here
not going anywhere I see you don't walk
away from this